- one boom thank you thanks for doing
this man really appreciate it
hey welcome very good to meet you nice
to meet you too and thanks for not
lighting this place on fire you're
welcome
later how does one just in the middle of
doing all the things you do create cars
rockets all the stuff you're doing
constantly innovating decide to just
make flamethrower where have the time
for that well the flame I wouldn't put a
lot of time into the flamethrower the is
an off-the-cuff thing and so we're sort
of like it's sort of a sort of a hobby
company called the boring company which
started out as a joke
and we decided to make it real and and
take a tunnel under la and then they
then people other people asked us to dig
tunnels and so we said yes in a few
cases no event and then and then we have
a merchandise section that only has one
piece of merchandise at a time and we
started off with a cap and there was
only one thing on it was just boring
company.com slash cap or hat that's it
and then we sold the hats a little bit
limited edition I just said the boring
company and then I'm big fan of
Spaceballs the movie and in Spaceballs
yogurt goes through the merchandising
section and they have a flamethrower in
the merchandising section of space bulls
and eat like the kids love that one
best line when he pulls up the claim
throw it's like we should do a
flamethrower so we does anybody tell you
know does anybody go Elon maybe for
yourself but selling a flamethrower the
liabilities all the people you're
selling this device to what kind of
unhinged people are gonna be buying a
flamethrower in the first place do we
really want to connect ourselves to all
these potential arsonists yeah it's a
terrible idea to buy one look I said
don't buy this flamethrower
don't buy it that's what I said but
still people bought it yeah there's
nothing I can do to stop them
it's building awesome I said don't buy
it it's a bad idea how many did you make
you what it's dangerous it's got it's
wrong don't buy it
still people bought it I just couldn't
stop them how many did you make twenty
thousand and they're all gone in three I
think four days but it sold out in four
days are you gonna do a another run no
no that's it
yes well I said we would do twenty that
we did fifty thousand 50 thousand hats
at and and that was a million dollars
and I thought ok we'll we'll sell
something and have for 10 million and
that was twenty thousand flamethrowers
at five hundred dollars each they went
fast how do you have the time to do that
though I mean I understand that it's not
a big deal in terms of all the other
things you do but how do you have time
to do anything I just I don't understand
your time management skills I mean it
didn't spend much time on this
flamethrower I mean to be totally Frank
it's actually just a roofing torch with
an air rifle cover it's not a real
flamethrower which is why it says not a
flamethrower that's why we were very
clear this is not actually a
flamethrower and and and it also we were
told that various countries would would
ban shipping of it but they would not
they would ban flamethrowers so we very
to solve this problem for all the
customs agencies we labeled it not a
flamethrower did work is it effective I
don't know I think so yeah